- Hey everybody, let's
talk about lingerie!
- You wanna know how you
came into this world?
- Guess how much this piece of shit costs.
(hinge squeaking)
(sexy music)
- I'm a fan of lingerie.
I've never bought any from anybody,
but someone has surprised me
with some and I had to say
it was a very pleasant surprise.
- I think when girls wear
lingerie, it looks great.
I think any type of
lingerie is pretty sexy.
- I guess I'm, um, I'm a fan of it.
As much as I'm a fan of
One Direction, essentially.
- [Man 1] Okay, uhm.
- Okay, so this is a one
... I think it's a one.
Hold up.
- It literally looks like
a baby could fit in it.
- Like, wow.
- Dude, they just straight
up made a butt hole in this?
Like, what are we doing?
- Not much material,
you're seeing everything.
- You're seeing everything.
- So, that's my point of
the worthlessness of it.
It's like, why wear it, I
can see everything already.
- The butt hole thing, that's
gonna add another 25 to it
for sure, I'm gonna just
go with a hundred dollars.
- [Man 1] A hundred?
- A hundred dollars for
this one piece butt hole.
- I'm gonna say fifty.
- I'm gonna say 51 dollars.
(bell ringing)
- 40 dollars?
- That's a deal, everybody
needs one of these!
- These are the cheap ones, yo.
Is this the starter package?
This is what they, this
is what you start at
and you evolve something better.
- Body by Victoria.
- Who is Victoria and what is her secret?
- This kinda looks like a
doily, you know what a doily is?
Like your grandmother might have these?
- (laughs) Yes!
- I hope my grandma doesn't have this.
- Shout out to grandma.
- I say 40 for the whole thing.
- 72.
- I still say like 30 bucks for both.
(bell ringing)
- I don't even think I'm
wearing 70 dollars right now.
- Oh.
- This is a set
- This is hot, too.
This is what, I think the
black makes it, like, more.
- See, she might mess
around and be missing these
with my short hair.
- 35.
- [Man 2] 35 dollars and I say 20.
- [Man 1] 35.
- 15, 15.
(bell ringing)
- Two ninety-nine?
- Like, two hundred and ninety-nine.
- That's what it is 299.
- Two ninety-nine?
- I don't know shit about lingerie.
- We got close once.
Okay.
- Oh, Agent Provocateur.
- That green and orange, it's like Easter.
- This is the equivalent
of, like, a visor.
You know, like, you put it
on, like, this is a hat,
but not quite, I still
want you to see my hair.
Then why are you wearing a hat?
- I'm gonna say this is like 95 bucks.
A hundred bucks, maybe.
- Imma say 14.99.
- I'm saying a hundred dollars.
(long haired man sighs)
80 dollars, 85 dollars, 80 ... 85 dollars.
- Fucking decide.
(bell ringing)
- For what?
- Yeah!
- I feel like you should
get a bottom pair for this,
or you get two for the price of one.
That's insane.
(inquisitive music)
- I just enjoy conceptually that, like,
you have socks as a part of your lingerie.
You know?
I didn't expect that to
happen, and I would definitely
buy that for me, myself, and I.
- To spend anything
more on one, just, like,
on a two piece set that's
more than 75 dollars.
- Yeah.
- To me, is just, it's insane.
- I'm trying to put it
on the secondary market.
- Right!
- We're going into business.
- Zack and Kelz.
(quirky music)
(hinge squeaking)